hace tan sólo unas semanas la tenista
china peng shuai acusó a un alto
funcionario del partido comunista de
haberla agredido sexualmente desde
entonces la deportista está en paradero
desconocido y toda mención a su nombre
ha desaparecido de la plataforma social
china weibo entre otras voces del tenis
mundial la w asociación femenina de
tenis pidió a china que deje de censurar
el caso de penn supuestamente de
sorprendente que se desaparecida
hay mucho más que decir aparte de
esperar que la encuentren sana y salva
si sigo que no es la primera vez que
china atrae la atención internacional
acerca de desapariciones forzadas en
marzo de 2020 la doctora de wuhan aysén
compartió una foto del informe médico de
un paciente identificado como sars
coronavirus la imagen circuló por la
comunidad médica hasta llegar a su
compañero el doctor li wen jiang quien
hizo sonar la alarma global sobre la
existencia del cob y 19 después que la
doctora zen criticara en distintas
entrevistas la censura de beijing
desapareció lo que hizo creer a su
familia que le habían arrestado a
finales de 2018
actriz fan bingbing que aparece en las
películas de iron man y x-men
desapareció del radar público durante
varios meses cuando nuevamente salió a
la luz en el mundo online se disculpó
ante las autoridades por evasión fiscal
y agradeció su éxito como actriz al
partido comunista chino en 2015
desaparecieron cuatro trabajadores de la
librería independiente hongkonesa cosway
beige uno de ellos hui mina y fue
liberado en 2017 pero luego fue
sentenciado a 10 años de cárcel por
espionaje internacional el partido
comunista chino ha ido incrementando su
represión contra las voces disidentes el
grupo de defensa de derechos humanos
save war defender se estima que de media
desaparecen 20 personas al día en toda
china por criticar al sistema oa sus
guardianes